SANTA CLAUS CONQUISTA
A LOS MARCIANOS.
Ahora, KID TV les trae el evento
especial del año...
por primera vez en la
historia de la televisión.
En este momento, KID TV tiene un
móvil en el taller de Santa Claus...
En unos segundos, nuestro
corresponsal Andy Henderson...
nos traerá una entrevista personal
con Santa Claus, desde el Polo Norte...
donde hay una temperatura
de 68 grados bajo cero.
Y ahora, KID TV presenta, via Telstar,
a Andy Henderson en el Polo Norte.
¡Hola, niños! Habla Andy
Henderson, desde el Polo Norte.
¡Sí que hace frío aquí!
Desde aquí, sólo se puede ir
en una dirección: hacia el Sur.
La vida aquí arriba es muy dura,
yo no sé cómo lo soporta Santa.
Desde que llegamos, no hemos
comido más que comida congelada.
O al menos está congelada para
cuando la recibimos.
Y ahora, echemos una
mirada en el taller de Santa.
Hola de nuevo.
Niños, faltan sólo semanas para
Navidad, y Santa y sus ayudantes...
están trabajando extra para que haya
juguetes para los niños de todo el mundo.
Santa es un hombre ocupado, pero seguro
querrá decirles algunas palabras.
- Hola, Santa.
- Hola, hijo.
¡Hola, niños y niñas!
Andy, me encuentras en
un momento muy ocupado.
¿Y cree que estará
listo para Nochebuena?
Bueno, hasta ahora, jamás
hemos defraudado a los niños.
¿Es cierto el rumor de que este
año usará un trineo con cohetes?
¡No, señor! Saldremos como
siempre lo hemos hecho.
Con mis renos, Prancer y Dancer
y Thunder y Blitzen...
¡Y Vixen y Nixon y...!
¿Nixon? ¿De dónde saqué...?
Demonios, siempre me los confundo.
Pero los niños sí saben
cómo se llaman.
¡Santa! ¡Ahí estás!
Tenemos tanto trabajo, y tú estás
aquí, hablando con este visitante.
Sr. Henderson, le presento
a la Sra. Claus.
- Querida, estamos en televisión.
- ¿Cómo le va, Sr. Henderson?
Ahora, quiero que vayas y
termines de pintar los caballitos.
¿Televisión? ¿Dijiste que
estamos en televisión?
¡Oh, Dios! ¿Por qué no me avisaste?
¡Mi cabello está hecho un desastre!
¡Hola a todos!
Venga, Sr. Henderson, y le mostraré
algunos de nuestros nuevos juguetes.
- ¿Cómo está todo, Winky?
- Todo está muy bien, Santa.
Así me gusta. Winky está a cargo
de nuestro departamento espacial.
Éste es el cohete de juguete
más moderno que hay.
- Usa combustible de cohete real.
- ¿En serio?
Me preguntaba qué era esta
criaturita extraña de aquí.
Winky lo hizo. Así se imagina
él a un marciano.
¿Un marciano? Vaya, no quisiera
encontrame con uno en la noche.
- Me pregunto si hay gente en Marte.
- Pues ¿quién sabe?
Bueno, si existen, espero que tengan
a alguien como tú allá arriba, Santa...
para darle alegría a
todos los niños marcianos.
Oh, Sr. Henderson...
Continúa, Winky.
La Nochebuena se acerca.
Ahora, Sr. Henderson, quiero
mostrarle más cosas.
¡Dropo!
Dropo, perezoso bueno
para nada, ¿dónde estás?
Dropo, despierta.
¡Despierta!
¡Por favor, apague ese
rayo de cosquillas!
Levántate.
¡Levántate!
- Lo siento, jefe Kimar.
- Dropo...
Eres el hombre más perezoso
de Marte.
- ¿Por qué duermes en horas de trabajo?
- ¡No estaba durmiendo, jefe!
Es sólo que no he podido
dormir últimamente.
Olvidé cómo hacerlo.
Así que estaba practicando.
Sugiero que practiques
cumplir tu trabajo.
¿Dónde está Lady Momar?
Fue al centro de píldoras a buscar
más píldoras de alimentos.
Los niños no han estado comiendo bien.
No tienen nada de apetito.
No me sorprende. Se sientan todo
el tiempo frente al televisor...
a ver esos ridículos programas
terrestres. Se confunden.
- ¿Dónde están?
- Están allá adentro...
viendo programas terrestres.
- Santa, ¿qué tenemos aquí?
- Éstas son muñecas nuevas.
Esta muñeca camina, habla,
llora e incluso canta.
- Casi como una niña de verdad.
- Así es, señor. Así es.
Sólo necesita cariño y amor.
- Bomar, ¿qué es una muñeca?
- No lo sé, Girmar.
- ¿Qué es "cariño y amor"?
- Yo tampoco lo sé.
¡Bomar! ¡Girmar!
Les dije que no vieran esos
tontos programas terrestres.
- Ahora, a dormir.
- ¿Tenemos que ir a dormir, padre?
- Quiero ver más a Santa Claus.
- Yo quiero ver más juguetes.
No, ¡vayan a dormir!
- Hola, Dropo. Veo que estás ocupado.
- He trabajado mucho, Lady Momar.
- He estado aspirando el cuarto.
- ¡Bien! ¿Está el Amo aquí?
Kimar está adentro, y está
bastante enojado.
Kimar, compré píldoras de comida
nuevas, espero que los niños las coman.
Tenemos hamburguesas,
espárragos con manteca...
puré de papas, y una sorpresa
especial: Pastel de chocolate.
Momar, me preocupan
nuestros niños.
A mí también. Casi no han
comido nada en tres días.
Es más profundo que eso.
Parecen perturbados, no les importa
nada, no quieren dormir.
Tuve que usar el rociador
de sueño otra vez.
Se lo mencioné a los Jefes del
Consejo y me enteré de que...
pasa lo mismo con los niños de
todo el planeta, en todos los distritos.
Algo les sucede a los niños
de Marte.
Kimar, como líder de los
marcianos, debes hacer algo.
Lo sé. ¿Pero qué?
¿Por qué no vas al bosque a
ver al anciano Chochem?
Sabrá que hacer. Nunca
te ha fallado.
Hablas con sabiduría. Iré.
Atención, Jefes del Consejo.
Repórtense, por favor.
- Lomas reportándose.
- Rigna reportándose.
- Aquí Hargo.
- ¿Voldar?
Voldar, por favor repórtate.
Voldar reportándose.
Caballeros, nos reuniremos
inmediatamente...
...en el trono de Chochem,
en el Bosque del Trueno.
- ¿Qué pasa ahora, Kimar?
- No lo sé, Voldar...
...pero planeo averiguarlo.
- ¿Dónde está Kimar?
- Debe estar por llegar.
- ¿A qué vinimos?
- Lo sabremos cuando llegue Kimar.
Seguramente vamos a pedir
consejo a Chochem.
¿Por quién nos toma Kimar?
¿Por un montón de niños?
¿No podemos decidir
las cosas solos?
¿Es necesario venir siempre
a consultar a ese viejo loco?
Chochem tiene 800 años. No se
puede desoír la sabiduría de siglos.
- Yo sí puedo.
- Caballeros.
Gracias por venir.
¿Chochem?
¿Chochem, estás aquí?
Anciano de Marte, yo te invoco.
Chochem, soy yo, Kimar,
y los Jefes del Consejo.
Te necesitamos, Chochem.
¿Me llamabas, Kimar?
Necesitamos tu consejo, Chochem.
Algo le pasa a nuestros hijos.
No comen. No duermen.
Sólo les interesa ver programas
terrestres insignificantes en el video.
¿Qué época del año es?
- Mediados de Septubre.
- No, no.
No aquí. Me refiero a la Tierra.
Ah, sí.
En la Tierra
está comenzando diciembre.
Se acerca la época de la Navidad.
- Eso lo explica.
- ¿Qué es la Navidad?
Es una ocasión de alegría y paz
en el planeta Tierra.
Para los niños, también es una
época de expectativas...
mientras esperan la llegada
de Santa Claus...
y sus regalos.
¡Qué tontería!
¿Y qué tiene que ver esto con
nuestros niños, anciano?
¡No hay niños en Marte! Tienen
cuerpo de niño, pero mente de adulto.
No tienen infancia.
Durante siglos supe que sucedería
esto. Cuando nacen...
...les conectamos los cerebros a
nuestras máquinas...
...electrónicas de enseñanza
cuando aún están en la cuna...
...les llenamos las mentes de
información en forma continua...
...y para cuando tienen edad de
caminar, ya son adultos.
Jamás han jugado. Nunca
aprendieron a divertirse.
Y ahora...
Ahora se están rebelando.
¿Qué nos aconsejas?
Debemos permitirles a los niños
ser niños nuevamente.
Deben aprender a jugar. Deben
aprender el significado de la diversión.
Necesitamos un Santa Claus en Marte.
- ¿Santa Claus en Marte?
- ¿Dónde conseguiremos uno?
Sólo hay un Santa Claus, y está
en la Tierra.
Entonces hasta aquí llegamos.
¿No te dije que era una tontería
consultar a ese viejo?
Éste es un asunto serio, Voldar.
Y un problema desesperado amerita
una solución desesperada.
La Tierra ya tuvo a Santa Claus
bastante tiempo. Lo traeremos a Marte.
¡Me opongo! Nuestros niños
están bien así.
No quiero que un Santa Claus les
traiga juegos y juguetes.
Empezarán a jugar y reir y
molestar por todos lados.
- ¡Se volverán un estorbo!
- Ya tomé mi decisión.
Partimos hacia la Tierra esta noche.
Rigna, Lomas, preparen la nave
espacial número 1.
Nos acercamos a la órbita
terrestre proyectada.
Disparar cohetes de babor
número 1 y número 2.
Cohetes de babor número 1
y número 2...
Ingresando a órbita terrestre.
Bien, Voldar. Ahora, a encontrar
a Santa Claus.
Enciende tu magnetoscopio
a la tercera potencia.
Estamos sobre alguna especie
de ciudad.
Así que a eso llaman "ciudad"
los terrícolas.
¡Qué primitivos!
Mira todos esos edificios por
encima del nivel del suelo.
Podríamos destruirla con un solo
disparo de nuestro Rayo Q.
No vinimos aquí a destruir a nadie.
Nuestro único propósito es llevarnos
a Santa Claus a Marte.
Ajústalo a la quinta potencia, y
veamos si hallamos a Santa Claus.
Usa un traje rojo con ruedos blancos
de piel y tiene una larga barba blanca.
¡Pero ahí abajo hay millones
de personas!
¡Es como buscar una partícula de
polvo espacial en la cola de un cometa!
Un momento. ¡Lo veo!
¡Estoy viendo a Santa Claus!
- ¡Yo también lo veo!
- Está en una esquina, con una campana.
No, está en la entrada de un gran
edificio, junto a un caldero negro.
Está en la esquina, Kimar. Es--
- Un momento. ¡Veo otro!
- ¡Hay cientos de ellos!
- ¿Nos llevaremos a todos a Marte?
- Sólo a uno.
Y con tantos, no echarán en falta uno.
¡Aterrizaremos en la próxima órbita!
Interrumpimos nuestra programación
con un informe especial.
Un objeto no identificado fue
descubierto orbitando la Tierra.
La URSS niega haber lanzado algún
satélite espacial nuevo.
Nuestras estaciones de radar
están rastreando la nave espacial...
...o lo que fuere.
La Fuerza Aérea ha alertado a
todos los comandos de defensa...
...y de contraataque. Estén
alerta para más información.
Señor, nos alcanzan las ondas de
radar de la Tierra.
Vaya, sí que les tomó tiempo.
Voldar, enciende el escudo antirradar.
- El escudo no funciona.
- Rigna, revisa la caja del radar.
El escudo ya funciona.
¿Cuál era el problema, Rigna?
- Un ligero caso de Dropo.
- Hola, Jefe.
- ¿Qué haces aquí, Dropo?
- Fui a la plataforma para despedirlos...
...y luego recordé que jamás he visitado
la Tierra. Así que se me ocurrió...
¡Tal vez te dejemos allí en lugar
de Santa Claus! ¡Ahora, ve abajo!
Ya me ocuparé de ti.
- ¡Dropo! ¡Baja inmediatamente!
- Sí, Jefe. ¡Lo siento!
Prepárense para aterrizar
en ese campo cerca del lago.
Silenciadores de cohetes
activado.
Roto-cohetes número 1
y 2, disparados.
Y todo por un hombrecito gordo
de traje rojo.
Otro comunicado sobre el OVNI:
El Depto. de Defensa acaba de
anunciar que el OVNI...
...desapareció repentinamente
de las pantallas de radar.
Se cree que el objeto se desintegró en
el espacio, o que es una nave espacial...
...extraterrestre, con la capacidad
de eludir los rayos del radar.
- Disparar retro-cohetes 5 y 6.
- Retro-cohetes 5 y 6... disparados.
Desplegar patas de aterrizaje.
- Patas desplegadas.
- Atención, tripulación. Habla Kimar.
Al aterrizar, Rigna, Voldar y yo
saldremos de la nave para investigar.
Hargo, Lomas y Dropo se quedarán en la
nave, listos para despegar de inmediato.
El Depto. de Defensa cree que el
objeto visto en las pantallas de radar...
...pudo no ser más que un meteoro que
se desintegró al entrar a la atmósfera.
El profesor Werner von Green,
nuestro principal experto espacial...
...aún cree que fue una nave marciana.
Sintonícennos para más información.
- Billy, ¿cómo es un marciano?
- No lo sé. Nadie ha visto uno.
- Yo no creo que existan los marcianos.
- ¿No? ¿Y qué harías si apareciera uno?
¡Gritaría!
Silencio, Betty. Estoy tratando
de dormir.
- ¡Veo un marciano!
- Tú y tu imaginación.
Ven, vamos a casa.
- ¿Quiénes son ustedes?
- Somos de Marte.
No teman. En Marte tenemos niños
iguales a ustedes.
- ¿Qué es eso que les sale de la cabeza?
- Son nuestras antenas.
¿Eres un televisor?
¡Qué pregunta estúpida!
¿Esto quieres hacer con los
niños de Marte?
- ¿Convertirlos en zopencos como éstos?
- Silencio, Voldar.
- ¿Cómo te llamas, niño?
- Billy. Billy Foster, señor.
- Y ella es mi hermana, Betty.
- Tal vez puedas ayudarnos, Billy.
- Buscamos a uno de sus Santa Claus.
- Sólo existe un Santa Claus.
- Vimos muchos en las ciudades.
- Oh, ésos son sus ayudantes.
Sólo hay uno verdadero, y ése está
en su taller, en el Polo Norte.
Eso vinimos a averiguar. Vamos.
¡Ustedes, vengan!
- ¡Suéltame!
- ¿A dónde nos llevan?
- ¡Déjalos en paz, Voldar!
- ¿Qué?
¿Dejarlos aquí para que nos delaten
a las autoridades?
Tiene razón, Kimar. Es mejor
llevárnoslos al Polo Norte.
Muy bien. Vengan.
Dos niños desaparecieron hoy
misteriosamente cerca del lago Wells.
La policía no ha encontrado pistas,
y parece que Billy y Betty Foster...
...simplemente se esfumaron. Hoy
parece ser un día en que todo se esfuma.
Mientras la policía local continua
la búsqueda de los niños perdidos...
...las Fuerzas Armadas continuan su
búsqueda del objeto espacial misterioso.
Bien, Billy y Betty. No hay nadie. Pasen.
¡Vaya!
No debo traerlos aquí. El Jefe
se enojará mucho si nos encuentra.
¡Espera a que mis amigos sepan
que estuve en una nave marciana!
¡No toques eso!
Miren.
Éste es el generador de antigravedad.
Y éstos son los retro-cohetes.
¿Esto se enciende?
Sólo cuando hay ondas de radar
rebotando contra nuestra nave.
Y entonces encendemos la pantalla
antirradar, y nadie nos puede rastrear.
- ¡Vaya, eso es brillante!
- Sí.
- ¿Qué es esto, Dropo?
- Eso es la señal del ascensor.
Se enciende cuando alguien está
subiendo hacia aquí desde la plataforma.
- ¡Alguien viene! ¡Debemos irnos!
- ¡No, no!
¡No hay tiempo para eso!
¡Oh, estoy en problemas!
¡Aquí dentro! ¡Rápido!
¿Piensas dormir otra siesta
en la caja del radar, Dropo?
¡No, señor! De hecho, sólo estaba
mirando para recordarme...
- ...que no debo esconderme ahí.
- Seguro.
Nos acercamos al Polo Norte.
Puedo ver el taller de Santa Claus.
Prepárense para aterrizar. Hargo,
activa los silenciadores de cohetes.
Dropo. Quédate en la nave
y vigila a los niños.
- No pueden escapar ahora.
- ¿Ahora... o jamás?
- ¿Qué quieres decir, Voldar?
- Si nos los llevamos a Marte...
...la desaparición de Santa será
un misterio para siempre.
Nadie en la Tierra sabrá jamás que Santa
Claus fue secuestrado por marcianos.
Tal vez tengas razón.
- Dropo.
- ¿Sí, señor?
Ve con los niños y no los pierdas
de vista. ¿Entendido?
Sí, señor, entendido. Los mantendré
vigilados.
Hemos aterrizado.
Anclen la nave.
Lomas, tú quédate aquí y ten la
nave lista para despegar de inmediato.
Rigna, Hargo, Voldar, ustedes me
acompañarán. Vamos.
- Activaremos a Torg.
- ¿A Torg?
¿Para atrapar a un viejito regordete
como Santa Claus?
- No necesitamos a Torg.
- No nos arriesgaremos.
Vamos.
Nada puede detener a Torg.
¡Van a secuestrar a Santa!
¡Y a nosotros también!
No si podemos evitarlo. Debemos
escapar para advertir a Santa.
- ¿Qué es un Torg?
- No lo sé, pero no le tengo miedo.
No va a detenernos. Vamos.
¡Espera, Betty!
- ¿Para qué hiciste eso?
- Si esta nave se va de la Tierra...
...tendrán a toda la Fuerza Espacial
persiguiéndolos. Vamos. ¡Un momento!
Vamos.
Debemos hacer esto rápidamente.
No podemos permitirnos más errores.
Hargo, tú cubre el lado de atrás
del taller. Rigna, Voldar...
...ustedes cubran la entrada principal.
Yo dirigiré a Torg.
- Voldar no está aquí.
- Rigna, sube y dile a Voldar--
Voldar, intentas demorarnos nuevamente.
Me has contrariado desde el principio.
- Te lo advierto. Cambia de actitud.
- ¿Terminaste, Jefe?
Sí, y tú también estarás terminado
si no eres más cuidadoso.
Oh, pero sí soy cuidadoso, Jefe.
Soy tan cuidadoso que fui a ver...
- ...a los niños antes de salir.
- ¡Aléjate de esos niños!
Eso será fácil. ¡Han escapado!
- Voldar, si estás bromeando...
- Pregúntale a Dropo.
Oyeron nuestros planes. En este
momento se dirigen a advertirle a Santa.
Es verdad, Kimar. Hay huellas.
Debemos detenerlos. Esos niños
no deben llegar a Santa Claus.
¡Síganlos!
Yo pondré a Torg en el rastro.
Torg, sal de la nave.
¡Torg, sal de la nave!
Billy, no puedo correr más.
Tengo frío y estoy cansada.
- Y está empezando a nevar.
- ¡Por favor, Betty, haz el esfuerzo!
Tenemos que advertir a Santa. No
podemos parar ahora. ¡Nos atraparán!
- ¿Pero dónde está Santa?
- No lo sé. Su taller debe estar cerca.
¡Betty, mira!
- ¡Es Voldar!
- ¡Es el malo! El que no nos quiere.
Vamos.
Se está alejando. Eso estuvo cerca.
- ¿Por qué se fue?
- No lo sé.
¡Atrás!
No te muevas, Betty. Iré a ver.
Ya no hay peligro, Betty.
Vamos.
Tengo frío. Ojalá no nevara.
Es bueno que nieve. Cubrirá nuestras
huellas y será más difícil encontrarnos.
Y también nos hará más difícil
encontrar el taller de Santa.
- Tengo miedo.
- Lo encontraremos.
¿Hacia dónde queda el norte?
- ¡Lo veo! ¡El taller de Santa!
- ¿Dónde?
- ¡Allá! ¿Ves las luces?
Las luces... se mueven.
Vienen hacia nosotros.
Betty, ésa no es la casa de
Santa.
- ¿Y qué es?
- No lo sé.
¡Buen trabajo, Torg!
Ahora, destrúyelos. Aplástalos.
¡Aplástalos, Torg!
¡Haz lo que te digo!
¡Voldar! Sabía que intentarías
algo así. Programé a Torg...
...para que sólo me obedeciera
a mí. ¡Suéltalos, Torg!
Fueron muy afortunados.
No intenten escapar de nuevo. Tal vez no
tengan tanta suerte la próxima vez.
Hargo, llévalos a la nave, enciérralos
y regresa.
¡No te saldrás con la tuya... marciano!
El peligro aumenta constantemente.
Tomemos a Santa Claus y vámonos.
Rodearemos el taller y enviaremos
a Torg a buscar a Santa.
No atacaremos a nadie a menos que
se interpongan en nuestro camino.
"No atacaremos a nadie".
¿Qué les pasó a los grandes guerreros
de nuestro planeta?
¡Marte solía ser
el Planeta de la Guerra!
Recuerda mis palabras, Kimar:
Tu compasión nos destruirá.
Santa Claus, juegos, juguetes,
niños riendo...
Eso lo veremos. Pero por
ahora, todos a sus puestos.
Torg, sígueme.
TALLER DE SANTA.
Ve por él, Torg.
¡No puedes entrar aquí!
¡Nadie puede pasar!
Vaya, ¿de dónde saliste? Eres
el juguete más grande que he visto.
Y estás muy bien hecho.
¡Por la Estrella de Sirio!
¡Santa lo trata como a un juguete!
- Vamos, Torg. Atrápalo.
- Se ha convertido en un juguete.
Rigna, tendremos que atraparlo
nosotros mismo. Vamos, Voldar.
- ¿Qué tenemos aquí? ¿Más juguetes?
- ¡Son marcianos!
- Santa Claus, vendrás con nosotros.
- ¡No! No pueden llevárselo ahora.
- Falta muy poco para la Navidad.
- ¡Guarda silencio!
Pero--
No queremos hacerte daño, Santa Claus,
así que ven tranquilamente.
¿Por qué?
- ¿Por qué tenían que hacerles eso?
- Es inofensivo. Se les pasará en un rato.
- ¿Y por qué no lo dijeron antes?
- Vendrás con nosotros.
Te necesitamos en Marte.
¿Seguro que esto es inofensivo?
¡Nunca había visto gente tan
perezosa!
¡Parados ahí como estatuas!
¡Hay trabajo que hacer!
Ahora, pónganse a--
Oh, cielos, oh, no,
oh, cielos.
La Sra. Claus se va a poner
furiosa con todo esto.
Torg, atrápalo.
¡Tómalo, Torg!
¡Obedéceme!
Olvídalo, Kimar. Rigna tiene razón.
Ya no es más que un juguete.
Será mejor dejarlo aquí.
Créeme que yo no tuve
nada que ver con todo esto.
¿Sabes, querida? Nunca habías
estado tan callada por tanto tiempo.
¡Vamos, viejo!
¡SANTA CLAUS SECUESTRADO
POR MARCIANOS!
¡MARCIANOS SECUESTRAN A
SANTA CLAUS!
...y la Sra. Claus ha identificado
a los secuestradores como marcianos.
Las naciones del mundo cooperan
con una unanimidad nunca antes vista.
Se trabajará hasta el amanecer
en el edificio de las Naciones Unidas...
...donde los líderes mundiales
planean la estrategia a seguir.
Y en el Cabo Kennedy, nuestro
corresponsal entrevistó...
...a Werner von Green, responsable
del programa "Astrobala".
Sr. Von Green, ¿qué está haciendo la
Agencia Espacial respecto de esto?
Están movilizando a todos los hombres
y equipos del proyecto Astrobala.
Y hemos acelerado la fase final del
entrenamiento de nuestros astronautas.
Ahora bien, la nave Astrobala aún
requiere 6 meses de vuelos de prueba...
...pero vamos a olvidar las pruebas
para perseguir a esos marcianos.
- ¿No es peligroso?
- Por supuesto que es peligroso.
Pero todos nuestros astronautas
están rogando ir tras los marcianos.
Cualquiera lo daría todo para
traer a Santa de vuelta a los niños.
La Tierra aún no ha reaccionado.
No hay rayos de radar. Parece
que escapamos sin ser detectados.
- ¿Cómo está el prisionero?
- ¡Está divirtiéndose! Es tan gracioso.
¡Sólo he estado con él cinco minutos
y ya me hace reír como a un terrícola!
¿Qué es blando, redondo, y se pone
en un palo y se tuesta en una fogata?
- ¿Y es verde?
- No lo sé. ¿Qué?
¡Un "marciavisco"!
En eso se están convirtiendo ustedes.
En marciaviscos.
Blandos. Débiles.
Ese viejo es un peligro.
Había muchísima niebla
aquella Nochebuena.
La chimenea apenas se distinguía
en la niebla.
Pero la encontré y empecé a bajar
por ella.
Les juro que era la chimenea más
grande en la que había estado.
Y de pronto...
¡De pronto me di cuenta!
No era una chimenea.
¡Era el conducto de escape
del Queen Elizabeth!
- ¿No les pareció gracioso?
- Sí, Santa.
- ¿Por qué no se ríen?
- Rayos, Santa, fue todo nuestra culpa.
- Les dijimos dónde encontrarte.
- ¡Oye, no digas disparates, Billy!
Todo el mundo sabe dónde vive Santa.
Además, siempre quise visitar Marte.
Mamá y papá se van a enojar mucho.
¿Eso te parece grave?
¡Ya me imagino a la Sra. Claus!
La Navidad se acerca y yo no estoy.
¡Le dará un ataque!
Oh, cielos.
Hora de la cena.
¡Vengan por ella!
¡Aquí está Dropo! Si yo
no puedo alegrarlos, Dropo podrá.
- Siempre me hace reír.
- ¡Hoy tienen una cena fantástica!
¡Hay sopa, y estofado,
y helado de chocolate!
No, gracias, Dropo. No tengo hambre.
¡Por favor, Billy!
- ¿Entonces puedo comerme tu helado?
- Claro.
¡Oh, me encanta el helado
de chocolate!
Debe ser horrible vivir en Marte.
¡Qué helado de chocolate!
¡Píldoras para cenar!
Supongo que si a un marciano le
duele la cabeza, no toma píldoras.
¡Toma helado de chocolate!
Oh, Dios.
Kimar, mira esto.
Eso no es un asteroide, sino una nave,
y nos viene siguiendo. Se acerca.
Imposible, Rigna. No pueden habernos
detectado. Tenemos el escudo antirradar.
Lo sé, señor, pero nos están alcanzando.
¿Acaso la Tierra tiene un aparato
secreto que puede penetrar el escudo?
Sí tienen un aparato secreto,
y se llama Billy Foster.
Te dije que los terrícolas eran
peligrosos.
Nos destruirán si se lo permitimos.
Yo no lo permitiré.
Creo que subestimamos el ingenio
de estos terrícolas.
Muy listo de parte del niño.
Repáralo, Rigna.
Yo tomaré acción evasiva.
Bien...
¿Cómo está Santa?
¿Y los pequeños terrícolas?
Vamos, deben estar cansados de
estar encerrados en este cuartito.
Oigan, ¿no les gustaría ver
el resto de la nave?
- No me engañas. Tú no nos quieres.
- Eres malo.
¡Eso no es cierto! Santa hace
sentir bien a todo el mundo.
- Incluso a mí.
- No te creo.
Vamos, Billy, ése no es el espíritu
navideño.
Por supuesto, Voldar.
Nos encantaría recorrer la nave.
Muy bien, niños.
ADVERTENCIA: Revisar equipo
antes de abandonar la nave.
- Este cuarto se llama...
- ¡Esclusa de aire!
- ¡Correcto!
- ¡Por supuesto!
Aquí es donde vienen antes de
salir al espacio.
Es hermética. Se ponen el traje
espacial y salen por esa puerta.
Cuando vuelven, la puerta se cierra,
y bombean aire al cuarto por ahí...
Cuando alcanza la presión del resto
de la nave, pueden quitarse el traje.
- ¡Qué niño listo!
- ¿Dónde está el control de la puerta?
No está aquí, sino en la plataforma
de control.
Cuando se activa el interruptor, suena
la alarma, y luego de 60 segundos...
...se abre aquella puerta.
Para darle tiempo al astronauta de
revisar su equipo una última vez.
En el espacio no hay aire.
Si esa puerta se abriese ahora...
...aspiraría todo el aire fuera del
cuarto, y a nosotros también.
Sabes mucho de viajes
espaciales, niño.
Va a ser astronauta cuando crezca
O tal vez más pronto.
- Santa, aquel reloj está avanzando.
- ¿60 segundos? Debe ser la puerta.
- ¡Santa, cerró la puerta!
- Oh, no lo creo.
Seguramente sólo salió por
un momento.
¡Está cerrado!
Yo no confío en Voldar.
- Él no es como Kimar o los otros.
- ¡No me gusta!
Bien, niños, tranquilicémonos.
Puerta de la esclusa
de aire.
59...
58...
¡Es Voldar!
¡Va a abrir la puerta espacial!
¡Ayuda, Kimar!
¡Kimar, socorro!
Cielos, Santa, ¿qué vamos a hacer?
¡Si se abre esa puerta estamos perdidos!
¿A dónde dijiste que iba
a parar esto, Billy?
7... 6...
5...
4...
3...
2...
1...
¡Cero!
- ¿Quién está en la esclusa?
- Nadie... ahora.
- ¿Qué pasa aquí, Voldar?
- Jefe, Santa y los niños no están.
¿Dónde están?
Flotando en el espacio...
...¡como el resto de la basura espacial!
¡Para cuando termine contigo, desearás
estar flotando tú en el espacio!
¡Feliz Navidad a todos!
¡Santa Claus, estás bien!
Pensé que estabas...
Bueno, cuando Voldar nos dejó
"accidentalmente" en la esclusa...
...y luego vino aquí y cerró la
puerta "accidentalmente"...
...supimos que debíamos salir de ahí
o estaríamos acabados.
"Accidentalmente", por supuesto.
Así que nos escapamos por
el tubo de ventilación.
¿El tubo de ventilación?
¡Pero el tubo es sólo un pequeño..!
¡Y tú eres tan grande!
Estás hablando con Santa Claus,
hijo.
- ¿Pero cómo..?
- No querrás que diga mi secreto, ¿o sí?.
Oh, pobre hombre. Se desmayó.
Como si hubiese visto un fantasma.
- Comiencen aterrizaje.
- Disparando retro-cohetes 1 y 2.
Desplegar patas de aterrizaje.
Lomas, luego de anclar la nave
y bajar la escalera...
...ve con Hargo a buscar a Voldar
al calabozo y llévenlo al Consejo.
- Será sometido a juicio inmediatamente.
- Entendido, jefe.
Hemos aterrizado.
- Abrir escotilla.
- Escotilla abierta.
- Escalera desplegada.
- Enciendan motores. Nave anclada.
¡Feliz Navidad, Voldar!
Bien, de pie, vamos.
¡Dropo!
¡Le estaba pasando sus píldoras por
la reja y me agarró las manos y--
¡Cállate, Dropo!
¡Kimar! Responde rápido. ¿Kimar?
- ¿Qué pasa, Rigna?
- Voldar escapó.
- ¿Qué?
- Se fue.
Eso sólo puede significar problemas.
Vigilen a Santa y a los niños.
Voldar volverá.
Madre, ¿ya volvió Padre?
- No, Bomar. Te llamaré cuando llegue.
- ¿Dropo también regresará?
Sí, Girmar. Ahora sigan estudiando.
¡Oh, Kimar!
- ¿Estás solo?
- No.
- ¡Vaya!
- Terrícolas. Billy y Betty.
¡Bienvenidos a nuestro hogar!
¡Y hay alguien más!
¡Ven! ¡Pasa!
Lady Momar. No estoy acostumbrado
a entrar a las casas por la puerta...
- ¡Pero ustedes no tienen chimenea!
- Bienvenido, Santa Claus.
- Ojalá haga felices a los niños de Marte.
- Lo intentaré, señora. Lo intentaré.
- ¿Dónde están?
- Empezaremos con mis niños.
¿Cómo están, Momar?
Siguen igual. Callados, distantes y muy
infelices. Están adentro, estudiando.
¡Bueno, dejen que el viejo
Santa los salude!
- Y los niños querrán conocerlos.
- Les diré que estás aquí.
...y/(5 Pi r²) para determinar la
órbita correcta desde Marte a Júpiter...
...por el vector A a través del cuadrante
17, con 12 megatrones de potencia.
¡Padre! ¡Padre, te extrañamos!
Yo también los extrañé.
Niños...
Traje unos visitantes, de la Tierra.
¿Quieren pasar, niños?
Billy, Betty, ellos
son Bomar y Girmar.
Hola.
- Está vacía. ¿Qué me das?
- Mi mano, para que la estreches.
- ¿Cuántos años tienes?
- Diez.
- Yo también. Girmar tiene ocho.
- Igual que mi hermana.
Tenemos otro terrícola que
quiere verlos.
¿Qué es eso?
- Están riendo. ¡Bomar y Girmar también!
- Nunca habían reído antes.
Vamos.
No puedo creerlo. Es la primera vez en
meses que se duermen sin el rociador.
Santa, mañana te armaremos un taller.
No será igual al de la Tierra, pero
seguramente te servirá.
Bien, bien.
Quiero empezar con esto para
tener el taller funcionando...
...y poder volver a la Tierra a tiempo
para la Navidad.
- La Sra. Claus es muy buena, pero...
- Santa Claus...
...jamás regresarás a la Tierra.
Ahora le perteneces a Marte.
Yo, Voldar, escondiéndome en una
cueva sucia como un gusano.
Me vengaré de Kimar.
Encontraré una forma.
¡Es fácil! Deshagámonos de su
amiguito gordo del traje rojo.
¡Stobo, eso sería suicidio!
Está muy bien vigilado. No podemos
acercarnos a él sin que nos desintegren.
Pero tengo otros planes.
- ¡Alguien se acerca a la cueva!
- ¿Quién?
- ¡Soy yo! ¡Shim!
- Está bien. Apaga la cortina nuclear.
Muy bien, Shim. Entra.
- ¿Qué averiguaste?
- El taller está funcionando.
Nadie sospecha de mí, así que
me metí y eché una buena mirada.
No se parece nada al de la Tierra.
Nadie martillando o serruchando.
Kimar le armó al viejo una
línea de montaje mecanizada.
Los juguetes salen constantemente.
El planeta estará lleno de ellos.
¿Sabes qué? Tienen un juguete
de lo más bonito.
Es como un resorte enrollado
que baja solo las escaleras.
Estuve tentado de robarme uno.
Quisiera juguetear con esa cosa...
¡Juguetes! La decadencia empieza.
¡Incluso te afecta a ti!
Pronto, todos los marcianos serán
idiotas alegres.
¡No hay tiempo que perder!
Debemos actuar pronto.
No podemos eliminar a Santa Claus,
pero sí podemos desprestigiarlo.
Convertirlo en un hazmerreír
para todo Marte.
Venga. Escúchenme bien.
El taller cierra a las 10. Los guardias
estarán en casa de Kimar...
...vigilando a Santa Claus. Ahora,
esto es lo que vamos a hacer.
- Hola, Billy. ¿Todo está bien?
- ¡Sí, Dropo, todo está perfecto!
¡Santa! ¡Cientos de miles
de cartas de todo Marte!
¡Qué bueno!
- Dos muñecas...
- Dos muñecas, sí, Betty...
- Tres bates de baseball...
- Tres bates de baseball.
Mírenme. Santa Claus, el gran
juguetero, presionando botones.
Ahí está la automatización.
La tecnología.
Bueno...
...eso es todo por hoy.
¡Cerremos el taller!
Muy bonito, ¿no?
Lady Momar me lo hizo.
- ¿Puedo probármelo?
No seas tonto, Dropo. Este traje
nunca te quedaría bien.
¡Tienes que engordar primero!
Otro día que se va, niños. Como
dicen en la Tierra, "Otro día, otro dólar".
Hola, Santa. ¿Cómo te sientes?
¿Estás cansado?
No, yo no estoy cansado.
Pero mi dedo sí.
Ha estado apretando botones
todo el día.
Creo que iré a acostar a mi dedo.
Niños, aquí está su leche. Pueden
jugar por media hora, y luego a dormir.
- ¿Podemos ver los programas terrestres?
- Seguro. Pero sólo por media hora.
¿Billy? ¿Betty? ¿No quieren ver
los programas terrestres.
No, señor. No nos interesan los
programas terrestres.
- Me voy a dormir. Buenas noches.
- Yo también.
- Un momento--
- Buenas noches, Sr. Kimar, Lady Momar.
Un momento, niños.
- ¿Se sienten bien?
- Estamos bien. Buenas noches.
- Buenas noches.
- ¿Alguien los ha maltratado?
Oh, no, señor. Usted y Lady
Momar nos han tratado muy bien.
Buenas noches.
¿Qué puede ser, Momar? Actúan como
actuaban nuestros hijos.
¿No lo ves, Kimar? Extrañan su hogar.
Extrañan a sus padres, a sus amigos...
Kimar, tienes que enviar a
esos niños de regreso.
Imposible.
Santa dice que tengo que engordar.
Leche condensada.
Pastel de chocolate.
Banana split.
Con crema batida.
Esto toma demasiado tiempo.
¡Ahora sí soy Santa Claus!
¡Feliz Navidad a todos!
¡Mi dedo no está cansado! Iré al
taller a hacer más juguetes.
Ahí está.
PRECAUCIÓN
CONTROLES
Vamos.
Shim, sostén la luz.
¡Sostén la luz!
¡Esto sí los va a desorientar! Estos
juguetes jamás serán los mismos.
Viene alguien.
¡Rápido! ¡Al suelo!
¡Tenemos suerte!
¡Es Santa Claus!
Está solo. Sin guardias.
- ¡Quieto, mi gordo amigo!
- Oye, Santa, ¿te gusta este juguete?
Mi amigo te hizo una pregunta.
¡Respóndele!
Silencio, Shim. Enciende la
cortina nuclear.
Mañana es el fin de la
Operación Santa Claus...
...¡y Marte regresa a la normalidad!
¿Dropo?
Dropo, ¿dónde estás, bribón?
¡Dropo!
¡Niños, su desayuno está listo!
- Buenos días, querida.
- Kimar, no encuentro a Dropo.
- No durmió en su cama.
- ¿Qué trama ahora?
¡Buenos días! Buenos días,
Lady Momar.
Oh, mi traje extra, el que usted
me hizo, desapareció.
- Sé que me lo llevé del taller anoche.
- Faltan dos cosas: Tu traje y Dropo.
Eso lo explica. Cuando encuentren
mi traje, encontrarán a Dropo adentro.
Debe estar en algún lado
jugando a ser Santa Claus.
- Ya me ocuparé de él.
- Oh, no, déjelo divertirse.
Debe estar en el taller, haciendo
juguetes. ¡Le encanta!
- ¡Niños, de prisa! ¡El desayuno!
- Sí, sí...
...Si no se apresuran, su desayuno
se enfriará.
- ¡Dropo! ¡Estamos aquí!
- ¡Está escondido, Santa!
Oh, ¿conque jugando a las escondidas?
¡Muy bien, listo o no, allá vamos!
- No está aquí, Santa.
- Qué curioso.
Oh, bueno, ya aparecerá.
Comencemos.
Muy bien, Betty.
De acuerdo. Vamos.
- Un osito y una muñeca.
¡Santa! ¡Detén la máquina!
¡Mira!
¡La muñeca tiene la cabeza del oso,
y el oso la de la muñeca!
¡No lo comprendo! Intentemos
de nuevo. ¿Qué sigue, Betty?
Un bate de baseball...
¿Una raqueta de baseball?
¡Esto no sirve!
¡La máquina no funciona bien!
Oh, cielos. ¿Qué más, Betty?
- Un tren de juguete.
- Un tren de juguete. Veamos...
- ¡Mira esto!
- ¿Qué..?
¡Pero esto no tiene sentido!
Esto nunca pasaba cuando
hacíamos los juguetes a mano.
Aquí está pasando algo muy raro.
Bomar, creo que es mejor que
llames a tu padre.
- ¿Padre? Padre, habla Bomar.
- ¿Sí, Bomar?
Estamos en el taller. Dropo no está,
y además la máquina funciona mal.
Iré enseguida.
Hora de irnos.
¡Shim, despierta!
Sigo pensando que es una muy
mala idea entrar al territorio enemigo.
Kimar y sus hombres no se
atreverían a tocarnos.
No mientras tenemos a Santa
Claus de rehén.
Si no hemos vuelto en tres horas,
ya sabes qué hacer.
Muy bien, Shim. Abre la cortina
nuclear.
Una advertencia: Si tienes
algún plan, olvídalo.
Si atraviesas esa cortina nuclear,
serás desintegrado en un instante.
Sabotaje.
Los cables están todos mezclados.
Dropo desaparece, falta tu traje,
y ahora esta máquina es saboteada.
Todo eso junto apunta a Voldar.
Estuvo aquí... y pensó que Dropo
era yo.
Tiene a Dropo. Y yo voy a encontrarlo.
Pobre Dropo.
- ¿Sorprendido de vernos?
- ¡Estás arrestado, Voldar!
Deja de jugar con juguetes.
Guarda eso, Kimar.
Nosotros tenemos un arma
mucho más potente que ésa.
Como tal vez sepas, tenemos
a Santa Claus de rehén.
Un paso en falso y tu amigo risueño
será destruido.
- Bien, ¿qué quieres, Voldar?
- Nuestras condiciones son éstas:..
Primero: Destruye la máquina.
Segundo: Liberaremos a Santa Claus...
si prometes enviarlo a él y a
los terrícolas a su planeta.
Tercero: Basta de juguetes
y alegría en Marte.
- ¿Y bien?
- Pues... Tú ganas.
- ¿Seguro que tienen a Santa Claus?
- Tú sabes que lo tenemos.
Querrás decir que lo tenían.
- ¿Cómo escapó de la cueva?
- ¡Ese idiota de Shim!
- ¿Y cómo subió tan rápido?
- Santa Claus tiene poderes secretos.
Muy bien, ¡manos arriba!
- Rigna, Hargo, Lomas, repórtense.
- Aquí Rigna, Kimar.
- Hargo y Lomas me acompañan.
- Bien. Tengo a Voldar y a Stobo.
Los mantendré en el almacén del
taller. Rigna, ven y llévatelos.
Quiero que Hargo y Lomas busquen
a un hombre llamado Shim.
Diles que busquen en las cuevas
a lo largo del canal de trasbordo.
Bien, Kimar.
Ustedes dos, entren ahí.
Pueden relajarse. Van a estar aquí
un largo rato. Siéntense.
¿A dónde vas?
¿No sabes decir nada más
que "Jo-jo-jo"?
Si estás pensando en escapar,
Santa, déjame recordarte algo.
En cuanto toques esa cortina nuclear,
no quedará de ti ni un bigote.
¡Oye, Santa! ¡Ten cuidado!
- ¿Qué harás con nosotros?
- Serán enjuiciados por el Consejo.
Creo que no causarán más problemas.
Creo que eso debería bastar, Billy.
Cierra la puerta, hijo.
Ahora, necesitamos pintura roja.
La hallarás en el almacén.
- Sí, Santa.
- Sí, qué buen chico.
Esta vez me ocuparé de Santa
para siempre, y destruiré esa máquina.
¡Santa! ¡Voldar y otro hombre
están en el almacén, y vienen por ti!
¿Oh, sí?
Tal vez les gustaría divertirse
un poco con nuestros juguetes.
Y nosotros nos encargaremos
de que se diviertan. ¿Verdad, niños?
- ¡Nos encontramos de nuevo!
- No sé cómo te escapaste de Shim...
pero no te escaparás de mí.
¡Estás terminado!
Voldar, ¿por qué no te relajas?
¡Tú te vas a relajar, para siempre!
¿Tú? ¡Pero tú no estás aquí!
¡Tú estás allí!
Sí, tienes razón. No estoy aquí.
¡Estoy allí!
Un momento.
Voy a ver contra quién pelea
Voldar allí dentro.
¿Qué pasó?
¡No sé qué sucede aquí,
pero me ocuparé de ti yo mismo!
¡No, espera un momento,
podemos conversarlo!
¡Oh, jefe! ¡Cuánto me alegro de verlo!
Muy bien, entra ahí, Stobo.
Está bien, niños. Ya pueden parar.
¡Dije alto el fuego!
Bien, Rigna, llévatelos.
Han tenido un día agitado.
¡Jo-jo-jo a todo el mundo!
¡Feliz Navidad!
No me necesitan aquí, Kimar. ¡Tienen
un fantástico Santa Claus propio!
- Adiós, Billy.
- Adiós.
Adiós, querida Betty.
- Cuídate mucho.
- Adiós
- Tengo algo para ti, Billy.
- ¡Vaya, gracias!
- Adiós.
- Sí que nos divertimos.
- Los vamos a extrañar.
- Me pregunto si nos volveremos a ver.
- Estoy segura de que sí, niños.
Gracias, Santa, por traer felicidad
a los niños de Marte.
Y por traernos el espíritu navideño
a todos.
Hijo, desde el fondo de mi corazón,
les deseo a ti y a los tuyos...
lo mejor de lo mejor.
¡Feliz Navidad a todos!
¡Llegó Dropo Claus!
- ¡Feliz Navidad!
- ¡Dropo, has engordado!
¡Sí, y sin almohadas! ¡Miren,
niños! ¡Nada de almohadas!
Si nos apresuramos, podemos
llegar a tiempo para Nochebuena.
¡Sí!
- ¿Nos vamos?
- ¡Sí!
Queridos amigos,
¡nos vamos!
¡Feliz Navidad a todos!
¡Nos vamos!
¡Adiós, Santa Claus!
Feliz Navidad.